from a jail in iran to south east london
a cry for help
greetings to you all this is anusha
calling from evin prisoner i'm sending
this message
out of desperation retired engineer
father and husband
anisha ashuri pleading for the
government to do more to save him
it is now more than three and a half
years that all we have received from the
british government
has just been words and no tangible
results
anisha has smuggled out recordings
before but this is the most desperate
sounding to his wife and daughter
and the most critical of the british
government i could hear the tears in his
voice
i could i could i could sense the
desperation in him
and that's it's particularly upsetting
it's it's it's very sad it's very bad
he's a doting father and husband who
loved filming his family as they grew up
now in jail in iran after being abducted
on the streets in tehran
while on holiday visiting his mother
charges the retired 66 year old was a
spy
are say his family preposterous anusha's
attempted suicide three times in jail
held for three and a half years now in a
crowded prison cell
tormented by the longing to see his
family again
will i ever have a chance to embrace my
kids again
or taste the warmth of my wife's
presence
only for one more time before we are too
old to recognize each other
when i come out after 10 years in my mid
70s
and that is provided that i come out
alive and sane
with my lovely dog romeo be still alive
will you recognize me and we hit trump
on my lap
alicia's family is sharing the recording
and speaking out because they say they
regret
taking foreign office advice to keep
quiet
the fact that the foreign office kept us
silent saying that that was the best
advice they could give us
i think that was the worst advice that
we could have had because
you know we are so behind with where we
could have been
by now in response to the family's
claims the foreign office said
we strongly urge iran to reunite british
iranian duel national mr ashuri with his
family
our embassy in tehran continues to
request consular access
we're in close contact with his family
and continue to support them
anusha is one of several british
iranians held in iran
taken as hostages by the iranian
government say supporters
to give it leverage in negotiations with
britain
the assures say the uk must do more to
help bring anusha home
before it's too late someone innocent is
in
a great deal of distress and his voice
is not being heard
and if something isn't done
soon it could be at the risk of his
sanity or even his life
dominic waghorn sky news